welcome back to las vegas now easter is
this sunday and our friends at smith's
food and drug the sponsors of this
segment are sharing a pretty cool way to
decorate your easter eggs with a whipped
topping chef jeff jackson shows us how
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's uh it's easter time and that
means time to color some easter eggs and
i'm going to show you today a really
kind of your kids are going to love this
it's a fun way to tie-dye easter eggs
using
whipped cream and some food coloring so
super simple really easy lots of fun
make sure to wear gloves when you do
this because your hands are going to get
dirty okay so i've got some hard boiled
eggs one thing i wanted to show you that
is kind of a fun thing um if you've
never opened up a can or a carton of
eggs and you didn't know if you had
hard-boiled them or not there's a good
way to test it so this one is a raw egg
this has been cooked you spin it you see
how that just kind of spins slow that's
how you know that it's
not hard-boiled where hard-boiled ones
will just spin like crazy anyway just a
side note if you're ever wondering if
your eggs in the fridge are hard boiled
or not okay so once we've decided that
they're hard-boiled which these are i'm
going to cover them with a white vinegar
and what the vinegar is going to do is
going to help the the dye to adhere
later on so just cover them with the
vinegar let it set for two minutes and
then we will continue on with the rest
of it okay so i soaked my eggs in the
vinegar for two minutes and then i
drained it all out and then what i want
to do is get them drying
um using just an old kitchen towel you
have it's not something that you're
gonna you're gonna ruin okay so what i'm
going to do now is take some whipped
cream now you can also make this with
shaving cream but i think it's funner
with whipped cream because it just if
you get it on your hands maybe you can
lick it off there but either way get
your sheet pan
and just take and spread
your
whipped cream throughout the sheet pan
like so and then get some food coloring
now what we're gonna do is put a few
drops
like so we'll use all different kind of
colors i've got pink and purple
just get have fun with it
let me put a few different colors okay
so i'm putting my last color on here
we're going to go green just as many
colors you want but don't do too much
because if you end up mixing too many
colors it just turns into a just purpley
brownish mess take a toothpick and just
start to swirl this around kind of
marble it
so this is something the kids will just
love just they can get dirty and have
fun and they can see the eggs and what
they do but just mix it around like so
put that aside and then just take those
eggs that are dry and put them in our
mix here and then we're just going to
roll them around
until they're completely covered so this
is as you can see you need to have
gloved hands because it makes a mess but
that's okay so get them all covered and
then they're going to sit
for 15 minutes
after those 15 minutes i'll show you
what happens you actually have to rinse
them off
so after those 15 minutes pass
then you rinse them off and then what
you end up with
is these beautiful tie dyed eggs look at
that really cool huh
so what i'm going to do is just put them
in our wonderful little easter basket
and we're ready for easter ready for the
bunny to hide these things
but either way
super fun and
you can find all these ingredients at
your local smiths thank you so much for
watching thank you for shopping and
we'll see you next time bye everybody
thank you again to smith's food and drug
for sponsoring this segment for more
information you can visit the website
that's right there on your screen
smithsfoodanddrug.com